dicen que la práctica hacia el maestro y
de hecho no sé si así va la frase pero
pero hay una frase una frase de un
matemático que dice que una buena
cantidad de ejemplos es indispensable
para él para aprender bien un concepto
así que en este vídeo lo que vamos a
hacer es eso voy a voy a poner un montón
de ejemplos y el primero es este 2.292
dividido entre 4 y esto es división
larga no sé por qué se le llama así
división larga tal vez porque tardas
mucho o por qué usas mucho espacio en la
hoja pero para atacar cualquier problema
de división larga lo esencial aquí lo
principal es saber tus tablas de
multiplicar tal vez hasta la 10 o hasta
la 12 eso te facilita mucho mucho la
vida a la hora de hacer división larga
así que iniciemos con esto ok
esta anotación es lo mismo que
escribirlo también de esta manera
simplemente son formas distintas de
escribir que 2.292 está siendo dividido
entre 4 también está 2.292 dividido
entre 4 estas tres son formas distintas
de escribir que la división a la
división larga ahora tal vez tú digas o
ésta parece una fracción y si en efecto
lo es es una fracción pero me enfocaré
primero en esta forma de escribir la
división y ya después veremos algunas
otras formas distintas bueno entonces ok
4 cuántas veces caben 2.292 vamos a
atacar este problema entonces no cabe
pero en 22 veamos
4 por 5 es igual a 20 lo voy a poner
aquí 4 por 5 es igual a 20 4 por 6 es
igual a 24 como puedes ver 24 ya es
demasiado entonces el 6 no nos sirve así
que vamos con el 5 pongo el 5 aquí
arriba 5 por 4 es igual a 20 como el 20
aquí abajo hacemos la resta 22 menos 20
es igual a 2 y bajo este 9 y viste en
vídeos previos lo que significa esto
pusimos a este 5
lugar de las centenas no es un 5 es un
500 pero en este vídeo me voy a enfocar
más en el proceso de la división quiero
que quede bien claro como el agua ajá
ahora aquí aquí bajamos el 9
cuántas veces cabe 4 en 29 como puedes
ver 6 podría ser cierto pero veamos 7 4
por 7 es igual a 28 así que al menos
cabe siete veces y ocho ya es demasiado
baja así que el número indicado es 7 y 7
por 4 es igual a 28 ponemos el 28 aquí
hacemos la resta 29-28 es igual a 1 aquí
pongo abajo el 1 y después de esto en el
proceso sigue bajar este 2 bajamos este
las veces cabe 4 en 12 está ya sencillo
porque porque sabemos que 3 por 4 es
igual a 12 3 por 4 igual a 12 hacemos la
resta y nos queda un residuo de 0
entonces 4 cabe en 2.290 y 2 573 veces
aquí también lo puedo poner esto es
igual a 573 veces que cabe el 4 en ese
número y también aquí 573 muy bien
hagamos otros ejemplos unos ejemplos más
hoy también cabe mencionar que la frase
que en que dije al inicio del vídeo es
el matemático por salmos
sólo como dato curioso porque vamos a
seguir con esto 7 cuantas veces cabe en
6 mil 473 ok es otra división larga 7
caben 60 veces seguimos 7 cabe en 64
cuántas veces cabe en 64 ok vamos a
pensar en esto
7 por 7 eso es igual a 7 por 7 es igual
a 49 de hecho es muy pequeño es el
número entonces deja pienso y en esto 7
por 9 7 por 9 es igual a 63 y 7 por 10
ya es demasiado es igual a 70 entonces
el 9 funciona perfectamente aquí 7 por 9
es igual a 63 hacemos la resta 64 63 es
igual a 1 y bajamos este 7 17 nos queda
entonces cuántas veces cabe el 7 en 17 7
por 2 es igual a 14 y 7 por 3 es igual a
21 el 3 ya es demasiado entonces aquí
ponemos el 22 por 7 es igual a 14
hacemos la resta nos queda 3 y bajamos
el 5 este 5 va para abajo nos queda 35
el 35 están las tablas de multiplicar
del 77 por 5 es igual a 35 ponemos el 5
aquí 7 por 5 igual a 35 hacemos
la resta y nos queda un residuo de 0 no
tenemos residuo ahora bien tal vez tú
digas o ella no he hecho ningún ningún
ejemplo con residuo que raro entonces
hagamos un ejemplo que tenga residuo voy
a inventarme alguno y al ataque ok
entonces qué te parece si hacemos tres
cuantas veces cabrá en qué número se me
ocurre
te parece ok 17 35 09 y 2 me quedó algo
monstruoso de este asunto pero pero si
podemos hacer esto podemos hacer
cualquier cosa cierto en la vida de
hecho hoy tenemos un millón 735 mil 92
muy bien entonces tres cuántas veces
cabe en este monstruo veamos de hecho de
hecho no estoy segura si es divisible o
si tendrá residuo
veamos si sumas todos los dígitos en
este número entonces podemos saber si es
divisible entre 3
tenemos 17 es igual a 8 + 3 es igual a
11 + 5 es igual a 16 más 9 es igual a 25
12 es igual a 27 27 entonces si es
divisible entre 3 porque 3 por 9 es
igual a 27 lo que podemos hacer aquí es
un poco de trampa puedo borrar el último
dígito y cambiarlo por por 1 ajá y ya
tenemos que la suma es 28 así que ya no
es divisible entre 3 y podemos hagamos
esta división así que 3 caben 10 veces
pero pero eso no es muy relevante porque
yo podría poner un cero aquí pero es lo
mismo porque 3 por 0 es igual a 0 no es
muy relevante así que seguimos con el
siguiente 3 cuántas veces caben 17
veamos 3 por 5 es igual a 15
y 3 por 6 es igual a 18 el cenieh es muy
grande entonces 3 caben 17 5 veces aquí
ya restamos 17 menos 15 es igual a 2
pongo el 2 aquí y bajamos el siguiente
dígito el 3 va para abajo
cuántas veces cabe 3 en 23 3 por 7 es
igual a 21 y 3 por 8 es igual a 24 el 8
ya es muy grande entonces aquí va un 7 7
por 3 es igual a 21 y restamos 23 menos
21 es igual a 2 ahora bajamos el 5 y ya
puedes apreciar por qué se le llama
división larga verdad entonces el 5 va
aquí abajo
3 cabe en 25 cuántas veces el 3 por 8 es
igual a 24 lo acerca bastante cierto y 3
por 9 ya es muy grande entonces el 8
queda perfecto aquí 3 por 8 es igual a
24 hacemos la resta y nos queda 1 ahora
bajamos en el siguiente dígito bajamos
este 0 pero que no voy a tener mucho
espacio después bajo este 0 y 3 cuántas
veces cabe en 10 pues tres veces porque
3 por 3 es igual a 9 entonces pongo aquí
el 9 hacemos la resta voy a bajar un
poco la pantalla y aquí queda un residuo
de 110 menos 9 es igual a 1 bajamos este
9 y tenemos entonces 19 cuántas veces
cabe el 3 en 19 el 6 parece quedar
perfecto 3 por 6 es igual a 18 otra vez
voy a tener que bajar aquí un poco
porque no tengo espacio entonces 3 por 6
es igual a 18 un restamos 19 menos 18 es
igual a 1
y bajamos el último dígito este uno va
para abajo
así que cuántas veces cabe el 3 en 11
cabe 3 porque porque 3 por 4 es igual a
12 ese número ya es muy grande ese
número nos sirve entonces 3 por 3 es
igual a 9 pongo el 9 aquí hacemos la
resta 11 menos 9 es igual a 2 y ya
terminamos ya no tenemos más dígitos
aquí los cuales bajar entonces ya nos
queda un residuo de 2 y esa es la
respuesta 3 cabe en un millón 735 mil 91
578 mil 363 veces con un residuo de 2 y
ahora puedes ver que puedes puedes hacer
cualquier división después de hacer este
este monstruo después de resolverlo creo
que ya te sientes capaz de resolver
cualquier problema de división nos vemos
pronto